welcome back to October top 5 I'm Walter
Bernays yak and today we once again
asked are you afraid of the dark its
worst episodes last week's episode
featured the best of our favorite 90s
Nickelodeon spooky series so are there
any bad episodes of are you afraid of
the dark the answer a few as stated last
week this series holds up surprisingly
well some stuff is dated of course but
overall it's just a well-made TV show
out of 91 episodes there's going to be a
few installments that aren't up to snuff
with the rest of them and there are a
couple that are pretty crappy which ones
you asked submitted for the approval of
the channel awesome Society
I call this countdown the top 5 worst
are you afraid of the dark episodes
number 5 the tale of the unexpected
visitor from season 5 this is kind of an
alien abduction story and it has some
pretty cool visuals so it's not all bad
Kiki tells the tale of Jeff and perch
who dream of one day being professional
musicians when Jeff tries to use his
father's satellite system Network to get
tickets serve something to see their
favorite band
perché messes with the system and sends
out a series of tones to random
coordinates in space later Jeff's little
brother goes missing and they slowly
realize aliens have arrived on earth
from the coordinates perch sent the
tones to so this band they're trying to
see wait Bret Hart and Razor Ramon were
in a band called world war 4 well say
hello to the bad guys I bet they're the
best there is the best there was and the
best there ever will be so we got to
talk about perch and pukin believable if
there was one character from the show
that represented everything
stereotypical about the 90s it's this
kid
we are not toys lady we are people
perché and Jeff also sing a song at the
end about not being toys it's a plot
point but it's awful
that's rock
[Music]
[Applause]
aside from perch this episode does offer
up some interesting set pieces otherwise
it's pretty boring I was dozing off both
times I watched it extreme bro number
four the tail of the Mahna ha from
season 5 there's some funny stuff in
this episode but ultimately the story
doesn't work very well
Tucker tells the tale of an eager and
resourceful young camper named Jonah who
is constantly demeaned by his counselor
Lani
Jonah's group heads into the woods with
Lani for their first real campout soon
Jonah discovers a cave with paintings on
the wall and the shaman appears warning
him to leave the woods as he has
released flesh-eating monsters called
the mana ha Jonah's fellow campers don't
believe him so it's up to the capable
young outdoorsman to stop the mana ha
before they capture his whole group like
I said there is some enjoyment in this
episode mostly because of the camp
counselor Lana how to survive in a bush
by Oscar but in relation to Seymour
butts
Seymour butts nobody seen what busted
you up
the main kid Jonah is likable enough but
I'm not sure if that's because he's
naturally that way or because everyone
around him is a total jerk or stupid
he's got quite a scream though still not
as good as so eventually the kid beats
them in aha by just not believing in
them
[Music]
hurt me makes about as much sense as the
Segway number three the tale of the full
moon from season two now we're starting
to get into the just plain bad episodes
Frank tells the tale of a pet detective
named Jed who starts suspecting a
werewolf lives in his neighborhood much
to his chagrin he finds out his mother
is dating that same neighbor he then
sets out to prove his case by breaking
into mr. anchors house while he and
Jed's mom are out on a date the tale of
the full moon is very clunky and makes
some weird random stylistic choices
Jed's mom has some out of place 50s
motif going on and I don't know why
[Music]
basically what this episode comes down
to is that I'm a boy and a boys supposed
to have a done this kid also apparently
has superhuman strength because he does
this overall it was just pretty lame and
just the slog to get through for the
most part number two the tale of the
virtual pets from season 6 virtual pets
remember those I had a sumo wrestler one
weird
vanch tells the tale of Kate who wasn't
big on computers while everyone around
her is very tech savvy one by one her
classmates start acting very strange and
are desperately trying to get her to
play with a virtual pet called a digger
she soon finds out that the pets are a
part of an evil computer program who was
replacing all her friends with
computerized copies this is definitely
one of the most dated episodes of the
show unlike the season 4 episode the
tale of the renegade virus this doesn't
do anything fun or scary with the
concept of a computer takeover the
villain is a picture of a dog that
repeatedly says feed me feed me
[Music]
this girl getting digitized isn't even
enjoyably awkward these are proceeding
according to plan the girl playing kate
in this episode was the lead in one of
my favorite goosebumps two-parters the
ghost next door here she gets to say
things like no that's a computer crash
this was another snoozer and heavily
dated itself with the whole computers
are taking over our minds idea clearly
they got that wrong and the number one
worst are you afraid of the dark episode
is the tale of the gruesome gourmets
from season 6 aside from a decently
creepy dream sequence this episode is
just really bad megan tells the tale of
brothers David and Tommy their mother is
a landlord who rents out rooms and new
tenants move into their house named mr.
Pym and mr. Collins
through an odd set of circumstances
David and Tommy are led to believe that
these new arrivals are cannibals and set
out to prove it to their mother there's
one star of this episode and his name is
Chuck
you ruined my paint job I'm gonna burn
you like toast toast Chuck really likes
toast
he's like Biff from Back to the Future
if he was even dumber I just found out
it's gonna cost me 200 bucks to fix my
car that'll teach him to mess with my
car that'll teach all we really needed
was a manure scene when the boys
investigate they're suspicious new
tenants it turns into a slapstick comedy
but not a funny one although this was at
least a little entertaining
[Music]
spoilers like anyone cares they end up
not being cannibals at least I don't
think they are the entire episode mr.
PIM and mr. Collins had been talking
about their famous pineapple cider
they get a glowing endorsement from
David and Tommy's mom near the end and
it reminded me of another blatant
advertisement what's the deal with the
cider oh you mean our famous pineapple
cider
I just bought some it's delicious why
don't you let me fix you some of this
new mo cocoa drink all-natural cocoa
beans from the upper slopes of Mountain
occur agua no artificial sweeteners what
the hell are you talking about who are
you talking to
oh and Megan eats a tongue sandwich at
the end yes a sandwich made of tongs
that's roast beef right not exactly what
is it well it's tasty its meaty its
tongue I don't know why that was in
there either are you afraid of the dark
didn't reach this low often at all
honestly most of the episodes are very
enjoyable and now that I'm older I can
appreciate some of the filmmaking
techniques sets makeup and effects if
you're looking to rewatch the show just
avoid these five and you'll be okay so
after watching this and goose bumps
back-to-back I feel like I have a pretty
strong perspective on the strengths and
weaknesses of both shows but which one
is better go ahead and check out a new
video on my personal channel where I
present my thoughts on this question I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your least favorite episode of are you
afraid of the dark what do you want me
to cover next in the show leave a
comment and let me know to stay in touch
like my Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B and follow along on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
back next week on Halloween for this
year's final October top 5
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]